uh you're now the owner of one of the  you know signature plays in finals  history with your block on eight in  there  uh i'm curious over the last couple days  have you watched the replay have your  teammates or you just moved on from it  entirely  i haven't watched it uh i think the  first time i kind of watched it was uh  today  in the film session we had but um  great play you know it's incredible what  your body is going  you know he's gonna do you know um when  you  when you're thinking about winning you  go to extreme uh  cannot explain the play but at the end  of the day you know that's in the past  you know when you talk about the past  that's your ego talking it's in the past  it's over with  you know i gotta move on i gotta keep  making you know winning plays i gotta  keep competing i gotta keep  finding ways to you know help my team be  great  so uh but great moment i appreciate the  moment great moment  we gotta move on